hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game a lot of you have requested
okay you didn't exactly request this one
you requested a
one hour game since he announced his
retirement from professional chess
after uh the uh candidates tournament
finished
if you haven't seen that i will put a
short link in the description below uh
it's a link to the chess based article
and there's a link to the video where he
uh
announces it for the first time so um
while uh that that is a very sad news
you guys have requested a very nice game
and some of you have requested his game
from 2013
uh from norway chess where he defeated
magnus carlsen but
i thought that was a pretty boring game
uh not not a boring game but
it's pretty long and maybe not all that
eventful and i know you guys enjoy
uh well much nicer games such as this
one so i chose this one
it's against hikaru nakamura it's from
the beatles chess festival 2012
uh and uh well this tournament went very
well for
for how as you'll see after we check out
this game
so without further ado let's check it
out and see uh why i've chosen this game
so how with the white pieces opens with
e4
now we have c5 by hikaru going for the
sicilian defense
knight to f3 d6 and d4 striking in the
center
uh we have capture sunday for knight
captures and knight to f6 knight to c3
and a6 the knight of defense is on the
board
uh we have bishop to g5 and now uh going
for e6
uh we have f4 uh grabbing more space in
the center could be a little bit
dangerous because
if you're castling kingside you might be
exposing your king to some unnecessary
threats but this has all been played
many many times uh so
it's uh it's all good so here we have b5
by hikaru going for the apologetic
variation
and now e5 house strikes in the center
right away
we have d captures f captures and now
queen to c7
seemingly giving up a knight but not
really because queen to e5 check will
win back uh
sorry not a wrong arrow uh will win back
the piece
uh but uh still e captures on f6 by ha
we have queen to e5 with check bishop to
e2
and now bishop uh queen captures and g5
uh we have castles now and here comes
rook to a7 and rook to a7 is
an extremely strong move uh just to give
you an example a lot can go wrong here
for black
uh for example if you just continue with
something like uh let's say g
captures on f6 which seems like uh
something you want to do because that's
a very dangerous pawn
uh you run into something like knights
to e4 now attacking the queen
and the spawn uh offering this knight
because queen to e3 check eliminates the
knight but black really has nothing
better so
check king moves now we're gonna pick up
the knight and now bishop to f3 attacks
for example the queen and the rook uh
and when you move the queen
we're just gonna gobble up this rook and
we're gonna have a much much better
position
so instead here rook the a7 just uh you
know gets
rid of the rook from this nasty diagonal
and the rook will be a very nice
defender uh
across the entire seventh rank so here
queen uh
uh rook to a7 with queen to d3 uh how it
develops now the queen
rooked to d7 uh getting the rook uh to
help out with
uh with the center of the board and now
knight to e4
attacking hikaru's queen with queen to
e5 now with a double attack on the
knight here
and knight the f3 now offering queen
trade
so rook captures knight captures queen
and now usually uh people play
queen captures on b2 here but hikaru
went back queen to c7 now uh house queen
is still under attack
so queen to e3 and now comes bishop to
b7 so just nicely continuing development
we have knight after g5 now this is uh
this is a very nice move it's it's just
bringing more pieces into the attack and
you know good things will happen
uh hikaru immediately chases it away we
have h6
and now uh now now a queen to
h3 just spinning that um h pawn
uh if you go for something like captures
and captures uh
it it could be played maybe in a blitz
game but uh you know in a serious game
maybe not so much
although it would be it would not be
easy for black to
bury all the all the threats here so
okay after h6 we have queen to h3 now
you cannot capture the knight because
the rook hangs
and now uh there is one game where queen
the e5 was played
but here we have g6 and it is only now
as of move 18 that we have a completely
new game
but also as they was played in 2012 this
position has never been reached again
so here bishop to d3 uh the bishop is
now
uh well much much better here uh also
adding another defender to the knight
and in the future there might be some
ideas like knight captures on e6 bishop
captures and g6 and so on
so here knight to c6 hikaru needs to
continue development and
now king the h1 now you you either
sacrifice here on f7
and then you just continue queen
captures an e6 or you prepare it a
little bit
how decided to prepare a little bit with
king to h1
like i said could be dangerous opening
up this diagonal so he
brings the king back and now knight the
e5 by hikaru
uh we have rook eight to e1 and now you
need to develop
the last piece that is the bishop on f8
so bishop to b4
now attacking this rook and you can't
really play c3 or something like this
because rook captures on d3
attacks the queen and black just wins
this so instead
after bishop to b4 we have rook to e3
a very nice rook lift and now bishop to
d5 hikaru adds another defender to the
e6 pawn
and now hao needs to to do something he
plays bishop back to e2 he doesn't want
to allow any unnecessary traits here
and here hikaru can grab a pawn so
bishop to e2 is a is a pretty uh
sneaky move but uh it's definitely best
to capture this pawn if hikaru captures
the pawn
uh then you don't really have any good
discoveries yes the knight and e5
is not defended but if you play
something like knight to c3
uh we can just eliminate it still we're
defending the knight after b
captures then we just go back knight to
c4
attack this rook and it captures and
captures for example rook
after e1 yes white does have a a
a nice position but he doesn't really
have compensation so black black
should be better here uh so instead
after bishop to e2 we have
knights to c4 right away hikaru not
interested in grabbing the pawn
and now rook the d3 we have queen to e5
uh now with uh with a a double attack on
this e4 pawn
and now a3 chasing away the bishop on b4
and now comes bishop to a5 with bishop
to g4
uh how it just brings all of his pieces
into the attack he really doesn't care
about
anything especially not that the b2 pawn
first he offered he called the c2 pawn
now he's offering the b2 pawn
but hikaru doesn't grab that one either
but knight captures on b2
is the best move for black because it
attacks the knight
and if you play something like rook to
e3 yes it looks very dangerous there
could be a lot of very nasty discoveries
but not really we just go back knight to
c4
and there are no good discoveries you
cannot move the knight even knight to c5
is impossible because then the queen
just eliminates this knight and you
don't want to
give up two knights to win this rook on
d7 so here you don't really have a good
move the rook is under attack rookie two
just king d8
now you don't have any any checks any
tricks and here black is just better
so this is the second time hikaru does
not grab a pawn
where he should have uh and now comes
knight
the d6 by hikaru and his position is
excellent
or maybe even better uh if there wasn't
for this one particular move that uh
how can place so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find
this the only good move for how while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on
finding this incredible move and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's a
queen captures on h6 i'm only kidding no
it's not
uh it's rook captures on d5 and now the
problem
is you cannot capture with the pawn
because bishop captures on d7 with
check and the black's entire position
just falls apart for example king f8 and
knight captures on d6
and there's not much to be played here
queen captures
still this is not an option because the
rook hangs we can even play bishop to e6
here go after the f7 pawn
give up the pawn here but now comes
knight captures with check
king f7 we go back knight g5 check again
you cannot capture because the rook
hangs
so after king to f8 level let's say f7
and black's position
is just unplayable this rook is stuck
here and that's
that's just it very very quickly uh
we're gonna win this game
so instead of doing that after rook
captures on d5 hikaru of course played
queen captures on d5 but now
bishop captures an e6 this was the point
we had to eliminate
the defender of the e6 square that was
the bishop on d5
so here bishop captures we have pawn
captures and now
f7 with check and now uh you could
capture this uh
and there are two very interesting moves
or rather three very interesting moves
here
uh rook captures on f7 is pretty much a
force to draw if you play out
the variation perfectly and i'm going to
show it because it's very nice
knight captures on d6 with check also
with a nice fork here
queen captures knight captures on f7 and
now
uh it seems like white completely
destroyed black however there is
castles here probably uh something that
hikaru missed because now the queen
cannot be captured
you will get checkmated so here best
would be something like queen to f3
and now the black queen is still under
attack queen e7 and now we go for this
knight captures on h6 king g7 now we
eliminate here check
grabs grabs grabs and now for example
knight goes back
and we play the same game where it's a
knight against the bishop where
howe would be up a pawn uh like i said
that's
very very hard to spot another idea is
king the e7 king the e7 also very strong
uh and with perfect play uh for example
after this king 37 we could play queen
captures on h6 hoping for rook captures
and then we just bring another queen
into the game
but there is a rook d to d8 uh so now
everything is
pretty much working out for black and we
would have to go into something like f8
queen check rook captures we would play
queen to g7 with check king to d8 and
now we're going to play captures with
czech rook captures queen captures with
czech king to c7
now queen to e7 with check going after
this pawn
king to c6 and now finally queen
captures and d6
grabbing the knight of course not the
pawn uh queen captures
knight captures king captures and we get
a very similar position although the
black king is a bit more active
so out of the two uh definitely king the
e7 best
and rook captures on f7 second best but
hikaru plays the third best move
and that is king to d8 and here uh the
difference is
that hao is able to continue playing
this game with the queens on the board
and since he's up a pawn
it could be could be worth something so
here knight captures an e6 with
check he car wants to hide his king on
the queen side king to c8 and
now f8 with queen uh we have rook
captures
rook captures with check bishop to d8
now blocking as the king left
the the d8 square and now knight
captures and d6 and here
again hikaru probably missed the tactic
i don't know why uh he didn't play queen
captures on d6
uh the problem is you don't have knight
captures and now okay the rook cannot
capture because of the pin but you can
just checkmate uh checkmate white uh
just
check and after the rook blocks this
will be checkmate
uh but hikaru first played king to b8 he
says it's not a problem i'm going to win
back my material
and now comes rook to f1 problem is if
you go
for for something like rook captures on
d8 then rook captures knight captures
and then queen to d1 is made in one
so here howe has to go back he plays
rook to f1
now there's there are no back rank mates
and only now hikaru wins back uh
his piece but now there's a problem
knight captures on v8
and again uh maybe even this is not a
problem uh
but uh it does appear to be hikaru
doesn't uh grab the knight back right
away
first he plays queen to c4 uh the knight
can't really
leave uh leave the d8 square because all
of these squares are nicely covered by
the queen and if you go for something
like knight here then of course queen
captures and f1 will be checkmate you
have to watch out for everything
so instead after this queen to c4 we
have rook to g1 by how
he's still up up upon so he doesn't
really care
about giving back the the material rook
captures and now
queen the g3 with check this also
eliminates the g6 pawn
so uh here we have king to b7 and queen
captures on g6
we have which also defends the c2 pawn
so here
hikaru goes rook to d2 attacks the pawn
and now queen captures an h6
rook captures on c2 and now queen to g7
with
check so now the situation is uh how is
up two pawns and if he can
uh start pushing those pawns then of
course it's gonna be an easy win
king b6 we have uh we have b4 defending
this
pawn uh by pushing it we have queen to
d3 now threatening to pick up this pawn
and now rook to e1 and now the pawn
cannot be captured because the black
king is in a mating net for example
queen captures now we're gonna go queen
d4 check
king to c6 not rookie six check king b7
queen to d5 with check and slowly but
surely
uh the black king will uh well will die
so king b8 uh queen to d6 with check
king to b7 rook to e7 check and that's
it king eight we're just going to play
queen d8
check rook has to block and this will be
checkmate so instead after rook to e1 we
have queen to
e3 hikaru now offers his queen so he can
deliver rook to c1
and then rook captures on e1 checkmate
but of course
how not interested in that just plays
queen f6 check
king to c7 and now queen to f1
so not falling for any tricks here we
have rook to f2
again hikaru goes for some tricks and
then of course if you capture the queen
you are again getting checkmated
but now how just plays queen to g1 now
pins the rook here
uh we have queen to f4 and now h3
and here hikaru played queen to g3 but
there really isn't all that much you can
do here uh how just played queen to h2
and it was in this position that hikaru
nakamura resigned in the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
the queen trade cannot be avoided
and after this is traded there's really
no no playing this europe two pawns if
you attack the pawn just rookie three
defends the pawn and then you're gonna
start pushing your past pawn
so uh so i don't forget these are the
standings of this
very nice tournament uh not that
let me just uh let me just slow that
these are the standings from the
previous video yeah that's the one
uh so these are the standings of this uh
tournament so as you can see uh how won
the tournament
uh by winning first place with 19 points
six wins three losses and one draw so he
lost a lot but he also won a lot of
games uh then magnus carlson in second
place anish geary
in third place hikaru in in fourth place
etienne bacaro in seven
victor bologna in fort and alexander
morozevich uh in last place
uh so really really uh a great
tournament for wang khao
and uh even though he lost both of his
games to magnus carlsen
in this tournament he was still able to
outperform him
out before him uh by you know winning a
lot more other games
much like uh for example uh mikhail tal
won the 1959 candidates tournament uh
he lost some games but he also uh won uh
much more games than for example paul
karas
swam really really uh an exciting game
hope you guys enjoyed it
and uh yeah aha retires from
professional chess or rather he
announces retirement from professional
chess we'll see uh what
he says that he will still be involved
like i said do check out his uh
video i will put a link to it in the
description below if you guys are
interested in learning more about that
uh but yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
sam console of kevin hawkins
austin del rio charles here and david
kimura for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day